two women have now come forward to
corroborate the latest rape allegations
against President Donald Trump I told
you a few days ago that a Jean Carol
went public with the allegation that
Donald Trump raped her in the 1990s in a
New York City department store the right
the trumpet's immediately called her
crazy wacky not trustworthy Trump
claimed he doesn't know her and that
anyway she's not his type which is code
for she's not attractive enough for me
to rape her well two women have now
confirmed that at the time of the
alleged rape Jean Carroll told them
about it they each had different advice
for a Jean Carol at the time and at the
time a Jean Carol specifically said
Donald Trump is the person who raped me
the two women are Carol Martin and Lisa
Bernbach Carol Martin admits that at the
time she suggested tui Jean Carol that
she not talk about the incident publicly
because Donald Trump is simply too
powerful and it would be risky to her to
go public Bernbach says that at the time
she told a Jean Carol go directly to the
police with what happened to you as we
know a Jean Carol didn't do any of those
things ultimately blaming herself and
ending up telling no one publicly for
years and years so listen first they
said no one would corroborate the story
now there are two people corroborating
it of course they will now attack these
women as untrustworthy they will say oh
sure now they're saying II Jean Carol
told him I told them at the time but
where were they back then which is
insane it would it be logical for
someone who is told in confidence about
a sexual assault and that person decides
they don't want to go public to go
around telling people about it that
would be ridiculous but that is what
they are going to do they're going to
attack these two women and what you need
to understand is that there's nothing
unique about these allegations against
Donald Trump Trump's own ex-wife
testified that Donald Trump raped her
during their marriage the Republican
Party just doesn't care about this
that's what you have to understand it's
easy to say well they simply don't
believe this particular allegation well
Trump's grabbing by the [ __ ] tape came
out and they elected him president Roy
Moore was accused of serial sex
Sault including against underage girls
and he got forty eight point three
percent of the vote in the Alabama
Senate race he almost got elected
despite those allegations and now he's
running again and why wouldn't he he
almost won last time so it's not that
they literally don't believe it maybe
some of them don't it's that they don't
care either way so why not simply say
they don't believe it either way they're
voting for the person we'll see what
else comes of this we need to try I mean
listen there have been so many of these
allegations and we talked about it our
video about Trump's child rape accuser I
think has hundreds of thousands of views
if not even more than that I haven't
looked for a while but it's clearly of
interest to a contingent of the
electorate but corporate media is
hesitating to cover the stuff in detail
and we need to see if any of these
stories will actually stick in some way
shape or form let me know what you think
let me know what coverage should be of
these accusers today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blinka s--
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa k
am